[Music]
Samuel leaves here welcome to this
week's winners on a Wednesday I wanted
to bring someone onto the show that's
having some property success who is
based outside of England so we have Gwen
all the way from Russia welcome onto the
show thanks for having me
so you've traveled from Russia to be
here now yeah recently we're currently
at the deal finding extravaganza correct
and every time we've met for any
training that you've always fly in yes
she's admirable so why don't you just
come with a background so in 2003 I left
the UK I decided to go on a journey to
Russia and I knew Russian a little bit
before studying at university and and at
school and I thought I could make my
career a lot quicker and accelerate it
as quick as I could by going to a
different country and being unique in a
different market so minus 10 so what was
your what was your business so I
graduated at a university I was working
in the city working in conferences and
you know delegates and organizations of
conferences and things like that and
I've got a phone call from the Chamber
of Commerce saying would you like to
come to Russia to work for us is it away
I'm not going to Russia I own a lot of
health chance that I'd go there and
literally within a month pack my bags at
my comfort zone so I'm going Wow and
turn into a year yep and then you ended
up falling in love yep says what
happened next on a family basis so yeah
I plan to be there for six months than a
year two years four years children
married so basically the whole notion
you know you just became Russian
basically pretty much I mean I haven't
got the passport yet but my children
obviously were born in Russia yeah my
wife's Russian so that it's fantastic so
so so now you living in Russia you're
working on your career everything is
going fantastic yeah what happened then
well with corporate life you tend to go
from job to job doing a good job usually
and then not really getting the sort of
success and pay and you know bonuses
that you expect and I thought to myself
a long term you know in the next 20
years that can't happen I need to take
control of my life control of my economy
yeah and thought to myself well property
is something I've always been interested
in I needed some education so I started
I changed jobs moved into the
construction work for one of the biggest
construction companies or developers in
Europe got two years education there in
commercial so I was head of procurement
for a commercial developer and on the
side I was learning on YouTube about
different techniques and strategies
YouTube is a fantastic resource right
it's incredible and at this point just
for the record despite your English
accent because you were born in London
yeah and grew up in London
you're about as Russian as anyone's
gonna be you're living outside of
England you're living in Russia your
family remotion your jobs in Russia so
for anyone watching this you are
basically living in the continent as
someone who's not in England anymore
you're not residing there so you're
you're on YouTube and you're learning
about property right and then what
happened so then I saw a video of
yourself along with Leslie towel yeah
and I saw Leslie and I thought to myself
this girl has literally got the same
story as me it's been abroad she's come
wants to come back to the UK
she doesn't have really a network of
people but she's got family there wants
to be closer to her family yeah and I
was looking at rent to rent deals but on
the HMOs and she opened up the essays of
area for me yeah I watched a video
literally got on your messenger facebook
Messenger yeah emailed her and said look
can I have a chat I'd love to work with
you which by the way just for the record
if you don't want that to happen with
you because now you've set yourself up
because it's interesting because you
were on you were watching like winners
on a Wednesday that wasn't called back
yet
yeah we're inspired by one of our
winners yeah cuz Leslie's an Academy
member came down start from scratch you
inspired by her yeah you've now joined
the Academy Leslie's now one of your
mentors yeah I am one of your mentors
you have a whole family a whole team of
mentors true you're now on winners on a
Wednesday so the this could now keep
recycling someone could now reach out to
you to end up at a crash course and who
knows in six months you could be their
mentor that would be ideal we know be
perfect all from YouTube true and I
think I think that you you really don't
understand the power
you know information yeah and a lot of
people don't want to invest in their
education and they want to try and find
so you know as much free content as they
can yeah which is fine but I think that
when I was looking at your videos I saw
those sort of the genuine nature of the
people involved yeah the fact that
people were investing their time and
energy and money in you and you were
giving back as much as you could to
their bill yeah and I thought that was
really you know important you know to to
go forward so Leslie I thought just came
across really well in the videos just as
much as you there's a big shout out for
Leslie by the way I'm sure she'll watch
this video he's just a phenomenal human
being true and she's making like crazy
money now so so massive chat and if it
wasn't for Leslie you wouldn't be you
and I wouldn't be sat here now he said
it was her story inspired you I mean
what were you thinking booking on the
crash course from Russia though that is
insane well look I've got to a stage in
my career worth thought okay I'm an age
where I need to really make a decision
do I carry on the corporate life going
from you know good salary to good salary
but not being really asset rich yeah or
cash rich so I thought to myself I need
to get out of that rut and create
something a bit of a legacy for my
children educational system back in the
UK is a lot better than Russia and
trying to build that platform back to
the UK somehow yeah not having
necessarily the capability or the kind
of the skill sets which were relevant to
UK so get going from a Russian
environment to a UK environment not
every employer would take me so I
thought what if I get myself
create my own economy create my own
company right now wealth I bear to do
that love that correct when we were
talking about that today creating our
own economies yes fantastic idea there's
a lot of uncertainty going on with
brexit and all kinds of stuff but it as
a property entrepreneur we create our
own economy right true so you came to
the crash course when did you come to
the crash course September September and
it's now November so that was literally
like six weeks ago yeah so he came to
the crash course was it worth the two
days coming down from Russia look I'm
not gonna start blowing smoke up
somebody's pipe I'll be honest with you
I've seen a lot of seminars I've been to
a lot of conferences I've organized
conferences
and I've performed alongside a lot of
people but when I was at that two-day
meeting or two-day conference with you
it was literally something which changed
my mentality and mindset yeah I've never
seen somebody so young as you with so
much energy and so much passion and if
I'd taken you know 20% of that passion
from you to be able to transfer into my
career I thought that I definitely want
to be around those sort of people yeah
so I thought to buy a ticket from Russia
to the UK spend you know two days of my
time of time to come and be with that
those type of people I'd definitely be
learning I'd definitely get an
experience and I definitely think it
would propel me to start acting yeah I
really appreciate that and I mean yeah
I'm I'm pretty good at what I do as a
trainer but also as you mentioned the
networking and everyone that's there
it's a whole new world and so you came
to the crash course six weeks ago you've
then flown back now for the deal finding
extravaganza there's you're going to be
doing more trips yeah
but when you come down you really try
making account tell us what you've
achieved since watching that video on
YouTube just yourself because you've
worked really hard from Russia or
remotely like and it's not like you've
been you're based in Russia but now you
live in England you've had to do be a UK
property entrepreneur whilst living in
Russia so have you managed to actually
get any deals I've got three deals so
far and they've completely gone through
yeah earning you money now how much
money are you making profit from those
three deals it's 1,500 minimum at the
moment but it's only the first month so
the occupancy rate is not at the rate
which I expect so 1,500 pounds is kind
of like worst case from the three days
how much money did you invest into those
three properties well obviously because
I'm here on a very very short-term basis
I don't really have the time to hang
around for people for delivering
furniture so I actually went out and
bought the furniture myself yeah where
potentially I could have waited a week
and leased the furniture so my actual
out-out goings were probably around
about ten to fifteen thousand pounds
sure therefore the three properties so
for the three properties you're talking
10 to 15,000 pounds yeah so around about
what
three to five thousand pounds each yes
but that was you being fast-paced and
not trying to cut corners yeah not
leasing furniture buying furniture which
is not a lot of money and you're making
a minimum conservatively a 1500 pound
amount of profit which is actually
coming in which is really incredible
yeah and you've got a lot more deals in
the bagging in the pipeline
tell me about that well one of the deals
I had with two flats in one new build a
block and the lady there she has a
service accommodation units already in
that area and because they did not
really had a good relationship with her
she said look if you'd like to take
another four or five units tomorrow
I will send them a letter kick them out
of the building and they're yours yeah
and I know they work because they have
all the business from the hospital etc
etc so that's one relationship I've
already harnessed over the two weeks
I've been here yeah and with another
building as well why just very very on
your off-chance was walking around the
town looking for construction sites
seeing which ones were being completely
just about to be completed and there's
ten units which are opposite the
hospital which I've just made a bid on
and we'll hopefully find a co invested
to go in with me to for those units
fantastic so you've got lots going on I
mean what would you say your the biggest
tip or the biggest technique that you've
learned that you're using because a
result of the stuff that the training
and the mentoring that you've done with
Lesley and mr. Feinerman on you know the
crash course and everything you've done
all together what's the the best tip
that you've learned well this there
probably be two tips actually the first
tip would be to just act on your
instinct and don't hold back they'll be
the first issue but actually once you
get if you're talking about si
specifically get onto the platforms as
early as you can and start getting the
bookings in before you even put money
down yeah so if you take in photos of
the property on your viewing put it
online straight away even if the deal
doesn't go through you can start to take
bookings and get cash in your into the
account before the actual deal goes
through for then what happens if the
deal falls through well what I'm saying
is is that you put the set the date of
when the the bookings can go through so
for example you were looking
I start the the deal from the 20th of
the month you would then put the
calendar at the 20th that you can take
bookings right yeah so it basically
gives you a bit of confidence and starts
you off on the right foot
yeah to sort of bother the winking
fingers crossed I hope it works before
you've even put any money down exactly
that's a really good tip actually and I
think that that really applies for all
property whether it's HMO whether it's a
single letter you can advertise it
before you've completed you can
advertise it while if there's a refurb
going on yeah in fact one of the things
that I do really successful if my team
is if we've got a HMO and it needs a
refurb we show people round while the
repo is being done every said this is
what it look like and they really feel
they really have a sense of ownership
like oh you're doing it already for me
they'll pay their deposit and then as
soon as it's ready boom you can move all
the tenants in serviced accommodation
you're doing the same kind of thing yes
and I love your first tip as well just
about if you if you know and get in your
gut and you've got your instincts if you
need to do so we just take action and
don't hold back yeah there's quite a few
people I've seen in the course and I
think that they're on the verge of
taking that jump that leap they just
need to be pushed a little bit yeah and
they'll go which is what I do right
exactly and I think that's the reason
why I joined the Academy well I went
with Leslie is that I needed that push
yes just that little gentle push over
the edge yeah to start and getting
involved to ask you a question Gwen how
feasible is it because everyone's
obviously on a different journey and
there's going to be Russians watching
this I mean we've got people on the
Academy that are from Poland we've got
people on the Academy from Germany from
Holland yeah
how feasible really is it if you're in a
job and you live in another country to
be part of the Academy Otto also or to
even just be a UK property entrepreneur
how feasible is that to be honest it's
not really sustainable I would say
advised that people that you can't
really be half committed to something
you either committed and you're not
committed yeah but how feasible is it to
be committed like is it possible really
to have a job and live in Russia and
build a portfolio in England I mean is
that probably not not just not enough of
a long-term level Oh heads a second
fantastic and let me sacrifice some time
so I've taken a month yeah to be away
from my children
maybe the financial freedom challenge
you just blocked off yes I'm income I
think it's also interesting because when
you live in England is easy to waste
time because you can think I've got
every Saturday to do viewings I've been
but when you're here every minute counts
yeah it was like a burning candle for me
so I've got a time limit and I have to
just quickly get in yeah smash
everything out apart it's what make my
financial freedom challenge you know I'm
starting tomorrow yeah I'm gonna be like
Batman because I've got no choice so I
mean do you think then if you're
prepared to make sacrifices and you're
prepared to come to England
every so often for a week or two weeks
or a month or whatever and just go for
it like crazy yes
is that possible then yeah definitely I
think you have depends on the situation
if you're a single guy that's got no
obligations no debt nothing you know you
can take your safe yeah come over here
and do that I mean I'm in a in a great
but you don't think though that you can
always come up with reasons why to do
something or why not to do it well I
think that when you limit yourself to
time so we've been doing exercises today
and yesterday where you're giving one an
hour one hour and a half where you give
them ten minutes yeah just to really
explain on that some people understand
so yeah we do an exercise where you have
to book lots of property viewings right
yes and and III give everyone an hour
and a half
yep and go go for it and run around
chase them do it and it was to booking
viewings and then I say right now we're
gonna do it all over again but I'm gonna
give you ten minutes yeah I'm a book
almost as many in the ten minutes as the
hour and a half just because of the
pressure and I think as well is that now
I have the three units under my belt
I've systemized everything in the way
that I don't have to physically be there
and now to take on the extra units will
be a lot easier to get under my belt and
then build the portfolio because your
your first deal is always your hardest
true so you've had to make sacrifices
but I mean I'll tell you something that
Gwyneth if you just said to me I'm
living in Russia I will be able to come
to England from time to time but it's
gonna be first taught a short burst of
time you know I'm not wanting to invest
a lot of my own money because I know
you've been a big spender previously and
you look after lots of family members
and things like that
yeah so you said you know I've not got
much money and I live in Russia
yeah houses how how likely is it that I
should succeed to be honest I would have
probably not said yeah do it join the
Academy it's only since you came down
and we've met
and I've seen how well you're doing when
I've been quite quite impressed I mean I
remember when I did a video rant I don't
know if you saw it did you see the video
ranted here
remind me what though I saw you you're
basically you was we were sitting in
your office and blatantly shouting at
people so that but to act on their
instincts and just go forward you know
because they're not doing you know yeah
you're taking their jobs and yeah yeah
it kind of irritates when people say
things like when when's the next crash
course in Birmingham and I'm thinking
what does one in London just drivers two
hours and I'd have ran on the video and
after I published that rant on YouTube
yeah we had about 20 people within a day
but gone all from outside of England
well that's one of the UK and I kind of
felt I was a bit like whoa pressures on
now I didn't I wasn't even speaking to
those guys I was speaking to people that
are moaning because it's two hours but
now we've got these guys travel in that
Wow you know this is gonna be really
interesting so can you see a real wave
of you know European property
entrepreneurs in the UK can you
visualize that um potentially I think it
depends on the level of English as well
because obviously come into these
courses things are very very quick and
fast and you if you don't understand
English very well it's gonna be
difficult to follow the legislative
people do speak English we're like you
know I mean the people certainly that
we've had on the program from Holland
and which they usually speaking is
pretty well you used to be pretty good
English yeah but I know really interest
in so before we wrap up then what will
be your final words of advice to anyone
listen any babies maybe someone who's
who's got an excuse that is I haven't
got the money I haven't got the time I
lived too far away what what advice
would you give to someone that's
thinking of reasons why they can't do it
I think that you only have one life yeah
and when you look back at your life you
have to think of the big bold decisions
you've made whether it would be getting
married where there would be you know
this or leave a job etc and I think that
you can continue being in that rut and
continue having that life but you create
your life that you want to have and for
me the biggest decisions I've made I've
been out of my comfort zone and when you
get out of your comfort zone the magic
really does happen and you I've in every
situation I've made bold decisions
moving to Russia get going out
completely out of my comfort zone I've
swam yeah and so I've basically forcing
myself into situations where I'm out
Mike
then all of the time basically joining
you know meeting new people gets talking
to people I wouldn't want to talk to and
when you start forcing yourself to do
things which are not comfortable you
start to develop yeah so I'd I'd advise
people to say there are actual hesitant
of doing something say to yourself where
do you think you're gonna be in a year's
time if you carry on doing the same
things you're doing and don't get if you
come for zone and start to change the
direction you want to be in I love that
really powerful I mean if you're not
growing you're dying and the only way to
grow is to be out and become the zone so
it's fantastic advice how did you feel
when you were booking on the crash
course were you feeling nervous were you
excited what was going on to be honest
I'll tell you that the last month since
the crash course I haven't enough to
sleep I've got so much energy because
when I've got when I was working I come
home from work you've been with the kids
I big kind of let's today's a call a
little bit you know sort of tired I
can't get to sleep until three o'clock
in the morning I just want to keep
working and I don't treat it as work
mail I wake up in the morning and I
think to myself I've got this to do that
to do but I don't consider it to be a
job yeah it's a pleasure it's a pleasure
to be talking to other people you're
talking to work because you're choosing
the path you want to choose you're not
dealing with the people you don't want
to deal with and you'll make it and
you're not working to make someone else
rich or I'm working on your dreams your
goals your legacy to leave yes which is
which is brilliant I know you haven't
officially hit financial freedom I mean
in one sense 1500 pounds onwards
probably 2,000 pounds already managing
it will be based on the properties that
you've got you know it's financial
freedom for some people yes I know we
need to work a bit harder yes um you've
got a lot of deals in the pipeline I'm
imagining that we're probably going to
do a part two at some point of this
interview once you've gone on to maybe
do 10,000 pounds a month in the next
sort of three six months how would you
feel about come back on the show
absolutely delighted - awesome thank you
so much for being here we look forward
to working with you
Gwyn absolute pleasure thank you very
much thank you so much for watching the
video that is the reason why I'm doing
this your success is my oxygen every
single week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success units you can do that right
here but what I'd really suggest is why
don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course comment
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can
what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out